teams can fill their days even though
they can't meet with players they can
talk to every prospect if they want to
unlimited number three times a week up
to one hour per time and mike reese of
espn.com reported over the weekend that
the patriots have devoted some of their
allotted time to talking with florida
international quarterback james morgan a
green bay native who models his game
after brett favre his his highlights
look good of course that's why they call
them highlights i mean
they're always going to look good it's
the low lights that teams need to be
concerned about but what's your thought
on the possibility of the patriots
adding a guy like james morgan to a
depth chart that currently for now
because they got rid of cody kessler
recently it's just brian hoyer with
jared stidham presumably the starter
this would be their type of guy mike i
mean this is a guy that when i did my
quarterback rankings on my podcast uh
when people wanted to know who was some
other guys that jumped out to me right
outside of the top five
james morgan is one of those guys you
know him and this kid named jake luton
from oregon state are the two guys that
i would say are six seven on my board as
far as quarterbacks i know everyone
wants to talk about jalen hurts and jake
fromm and everything like jalen hurts is
three years away from being a
quarterback in the nfl there's no way
you could draft him in the second round
to be a quarterback all right you know
he's a weapon he's going to be a project
he's way too raw and inconsistent as a
thrower the patriots like these type of
guys remember mike this is a team they
believe in guys that can really throw
the football they do that's why they
drafted ryan mallett and the drew
bledsoes of the world and the tom
brady's and
rohan davey uh okay and of course jimmy
garoppolo and jacoby brissette they
believe in that big traditional pocket
pastor morgan's a good athlete mike and
can really throw the football he really
can he is a talented thrower and can do
it all as far as throw with power touch
whatever it may be but he certainly
would fit the mold as the type of
quarterback they would look at i hear a
lot of people on tv going oh i think
they might look at jake from no jake
from's not a new england guy there's no
way
his arm is just not top tier enough for
him to go up to new england and bill
belichick to be able to ask him to do
some of those things and throw in those
elements james morgan on the other hand
is a guy i go oh he has a chance to
maybe be a really good starter in the
nfl at some point in his career and
that's to me the guy you take a shot on
you know in the mid rounds of the draft
how hard is it to watch the the film of
a guy who played against far lesser
competition and project that to the next
level i guess if it comes down to arm
strength that's transferable regardless
of what the exactly defense is
that's right you know again you you got
to evaluate the player and yeah you got
to see what's around him and everything
like that but hey a tight throw into a
tight window is tight no matter if
you're in the sec or in some you know
division three football game right mike
can you get it in there can he fit it in
with accuracy whatever it may be so it's
a little different for a quarterback
that way his skills and his arm jump off
the screen i mean you saw some of the
highlights and i saw your text yesterday
that you were impressed yes there's a
lot of throws like that you know when
you evaluate him and i i don't you know
hey joe flacco i could see the talent at
delaware right away jimmy garoppolo you
could see it there even though it was
small football so the talent is there
for this kid to be something
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports